hi I'm Chris Wilson from grinding Gear
games welcome to season three of build
of the week a weekly video series that
showcases interesting path of exile
character builds created by our
community today's build is a level 82
Templar called a la Lamas
he plays in the recently released
rampage League and is running a fire
over kill proliferation build his
character works by combining a lot of
different skills together
haroldo Vash causes any overkill damage
to ignite nearby monsters in addition to
the increased burning damage and reduced
managers that are supported by elemental
proliferation which causes this burning
damage to apply to other nearby monsters
as well Bolton's strike is a primary
attack skill of choice as overkill
damage is so important support gems were
chosen that do not reduce its damage in
this case it is supported by weapon
elemental damage faster attacks melee
physical damage and life leech the
avatar of fire Keystone passive is used
to further increase fire damage kallmes
primacy as the weapon chosen for this
build it's a high damage two-handed axe
that adds additional fire damage it's
important that a slow weapon respects
because they do more damage from one go
resulting in more overkill damage
proliferated to nearby monsters the
unique ring pyre provides a big boost of
burning damage and makes his item
choices more flexible as coal damage can
feed the fire as well normally pyre
doesn't work with elemental
proliferation because enemies that are
hit are incinerated
but the herald of a skill works around
this in a clever way because the ethical
damage isn't a hit so it's still
proliferated for this reason elemental
proliferation supports Herald of ash
rather than molten strike his other rare
items focus on armor life and
resistances crafted mods have been used
to fill in gaps to aid with mana costs
the clarity aura is used it is applied
to a slight fire blood magic gem and is
also supported with a reduced mana cost
to lessen its impact the flammability
curse is used to increase the damage of
both molten strike and Herald of ash
defensively the determination aura adds
armor if you want to spec this build
aggressively that we feel that the
hatred or will be a good choice it adds
a lot of cold damage 100% of which will
be converted to fire damaged by the fire
ring many builds use cast on damage
taken and a mortal call for defenses but
they generally combine it with an
enduring cry gem to generate charges
that make the immortal call lasts longer
this bill does not it instead opts for
the increased duration support gem to
raise the default land
vulnerability that immortal core
provides this is useful for stopping
bursts of immediate spike damage the
same gems also trigger an increased
duration molten shell the passive tree
for this build specializes in weapon
elemental damage fire damage life armor
increased area of effect and whatever
manner it can pick up the Avatar fire
kiss turn passive is used to greatly
amplify the character's fire damage due
to the quantity of fire damage this is a
very appropriate build for this Keystone
resolute technique is also used because
this isn't a crit build and uses a slow
weapon it's very important that every
hit lands and incredibly powerful
notable for this build to get his holy
fire which causes a lot of extra burning
damage we enjoyed this build because it
combined a bunch of interesting tricks
related to fire these tricks were both
new and old some well-understood systems
and some new forsaken masters ones were
used in interesting ways like having the
new herald of ash skill bypass pious
corpse destruction it's also nice to see
a mere label that encourages the use of
slow heavy weapons if you're new to path
of Exile would like to play just head on
over to path of Exile calm or search for
it on Steam we recently released the
forsaken masters expansion and new
leagues with fresh economies so it's a
great time to get into the game if you'd
like to submit a build for next week's
episode just post a build guide in the
class forums on path of Exile calm
thanks for watching and see you next
time